classic duas there Jamia figures Ralph  yeah and the vashiella graph has just  beaten Vincent so he's there up with two  and a half points  very much Champion  a little chat there  guys seem in good spirits  nihal with the  with the water bottle  yeah one can see that hiko is enjoying  the event Diana three out of three good  start good emotions everything is  possible sky is the limit  don't mess with me out has tried water  bottle  nihal is always so focused I think this  is the reason why he's so extremely  strong and that he can he can just  concentrate so well regardless if he has  two seconds on the clock whatever he  just never loses the focus  doesn't matter to him